Clinton made the release of the report, a major event that included Congressional leaders...
...and activists from around the world saluted these anti-trafficking heroes.
The trafficking of persons for forced labor, sexual exploitation and other illicit purposes, Clinton said,...
...is modern-day slavery and affects every country including the United States.
She said the annual report is aimed at encouraging nations to act.
We hope to shine the light brightly on the scope and scale of modern slavery...
...so all governments can see where progress has been made,...
...and where more is needed.
Trafficking thrives in the shadows...
...and it can be easy to dismiss it as something that happens to someone else, somewhere else,...
...but that's not the case.
The report assessed 175 countries based on information from US embassies and non-governmental groups,...
...it gave 17 of them the lowest rating.
The countries rated worst include Burma, North Korea, Fiji and Papua New Guinea in Asia.
In Latin America, Cuba.
In the Middle East and Africa; Iran, Kuwait, Saudi Arabia, Syria and Sudan.
Chad, Niger, Zimbabwe and Malaysia had poor ratings last year and are in the lowest category this year.
Eritrea, Mauritania and Swaziland are also listed in the so-called, Tier 3.
At the same time, Algeria, Oman, Qatar and Moldova, Tier 3 last year...
...are all recognized this year for anti-trafficking efforts.
Luis de Baca is the State Department's anti-trafficking coordinator,...
...he said, the main point of the exercise is to encourage improvement.
The successes are clear,...
...some former Tier 2 watch list countries are now Tier 1.
They have become models through their efforts for their regions and for the world.